joe biden picks kamala harris for vp and
the trump campaign is rightly licking
its chops get ready
the campaign is on i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn if
you don't like the government spying on
you
visit expressvpn.com to stay safely
anonymous so so it has happened joe
biden finally picked his vp or
as i like to put it heiress apparent
harris a parent you got it you got it
got it because he is not going to live
through his first term
okay i know we're not supposed to say
that i know we're not supposed to say
that but
six in 10 americans agree with me
including some 57 percent of
independents and 49
of democrats the reason that the vp pick
matters this time and i have been a
longtime advocate
of the notion that the vp pick does not
matter nearly at all it matters this
time because
everyone assumes that joe biden is at
the very least not going to run for
re-election
and probably will not finish his first
term he himself has called himself a
transitional candidate he is obviously
in a state of cognitive decline
it is perfectly obvious to everyone and
at this point president trump should
simply ignore joe biden and go directly
after kamala harris and say this is the
next president of the united states
not joe biden and joe biden made her the
issue see this is a real strategic
blunder by biden
i'm frankly amused and astonished by the
number of people
in the conventional political class who
have suggested that this was the safest
pick this was the
pick that made the most sense it makes
no sense at all
none biden's entire campaign is
predicated on the assumption
that joe biden is basically a return to
normalcy
he is a non-threatening elderly
grandfatherly character who is not going
to threaten
anything about the way america was
running before president trump became
president he's not a radical he's not
transformative he's just a dude and
because he's just a dude and kind of an
elderly daughtering dude at that you
don't have to worry about joe biden you
don't have to worry about chaos in the
streets you don't have to worry about
the crazy tweets coming out of the white
house
all you have to do is simply go about
your business and joe biden will have
your back that was the biden campaign in
a nutshell and so you should focus when
you go into the voting booth on his
opponent should focus on the volatility
and the and the kind of craziness of
donald trump's presidency
when you choose to vote so when he
picked a vp
he should have underscored those
strengths right what he should have done
is he should have picked somebody like
amy klobuchar he should have picked
somebody who was inherently
non-threatening somebody that the
american public widely perceives to be
somewhat moderate
instead he decided to cave to the
twitter audi
and he made this mistake for a couple of
reasons first he decided very early on
that he was going to pick a woman well
as soon as you say that you are
basically going to pick a vp based on
tokenistic concerns
and let's face it that is a tokenistic
concern whether your vp is a woman
okay that that does not say anything
about her character it does not say
anything about her politics nikki haley
is a woman
the idea that this is a criteria for
picking the vp
is the is the sex to which they belong
is a bizarre idea on its face and
becomes even more bizarre when you
realize that the democratic party
platform at this point is that women
don't exist and a man
can be a woman so as my friend matt
walsh has pointed out it's very bizarre
that the media are championing
first female black vp pick by a democrat
just incredible incredible stuff they
don't even believe women exist so i'm
wondering what's so historic
about an individual with the cervix as
the media might put it being selected as
the vp candidate
they can't they literally say there are
no differences between men and women to
the point where a man can be a woman but
it's very historic
that kamala harris is in fact a woman in
any case joe biden
early on signaled he was going to pick a
woman well this boxed him in but it
didn't box him in that much because
there was still a bevy of qualified
women who are out there then
because he had already caved to okay i
have to pick somebody who is
representative of a particular
demographic population in the united
states
then he was pushed into okay it has to
be a black woman it has to be a woman of
color
okay so he he sort of between
black women and women of color
and finally he settled on kamala harris
and she was
probably the worst available pick there
there are some other people who are up
for this thing
revel demings in florida largely
anonymous but at least not disliked by
the american public
he had karen bass in california who's
kind of a communist but again not very
well known
and at least had significant support in
the black community as the longtime head
of the congressional black caucus
and then you had kamala harris a woman
so deeply unpopular that she dropped out
of the presidential race
before her voters in california even had
a chance to vote on her she was
registering at seven percent
in the california primaries kamala
harris was such a bad candidate
that after jumping to the lead early on
in the race based again
on those twitter blue check marks
checking particular boxes woman
black well she jumps at the top of the
race and then she immediately flamed out
because it turns out that she's garbage
at this she's a terrible politician
she's manipulative she's machiavellian
she has
very few principles and what principles
she does have are radical
and that's who joe biden chose is that
supposed to make people feel sanguine
about the future of the country
is that supposed to make people feel
comforted and solidified in their belief
that he is in fact a moderate who's
going to
carry america on gentle waves to better
days is that really
the the pick that makes a lot of sense
the answer of course is no
and so the media have been attempting to
spin this thing as though
harris is moderate this is an incredible
attempt it really is
because as we will examine throughout
today's show and in the coming days
kamala harris is not only not a moderate
she's extraordinarily radical in her
policies she's been rated one of the
most liberal senators
in the united states senate gov track
dot us
rated her as the fourth most liberal
senator in the united states senator
in the united states senate just behind
bernie sanders and kirsten gillibrand
she voted with bernie sanders 92 of the
time while she was in
the senate okay that is not a moderate
and she's not a pragmatist either she is
she's a hardcore
leftist who is pragmatic only in the
sense that she will do nearly anything
to get ahead politically she will switch
her positions
she will flip on a dime she will make
accusations that are
really ugly about people simply to push
herself forward
if i'm joe biden i'm getting a food
taster today today
do not have kamala harris in the same
room when you're eating lunch joe biden
for your own preservation at the very
least you might want some life insurance
we'll get some more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that your cell phone bill
does not have to be
the same every month it can change and
right now you are paying far too much
for your cell phone but like hundreds of
dollars a month
why why who's your wireless provider is
it att verizon t-mobile what if i told
you that pure talk usa
uses the exact same network as one of
those carriers same tower same exact
coverage but literally cost you half the
money
how do they make it so affordable well
first they cut out the retail stores so
you're not funding
billion-dollar ad campaigns and you're
only paying for the data you need so
instead of paying for unlimited data
that you're not actually using you're
only paying for the data you need there
is no contract no excessive fees you'll
just enjoy
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
all for just 20 bucks a month
the average person is saving 400 bucks a
year on their wireless bill which is a
lot of money
in these trying times grab your mobile
phone dial pound 250
and say ben shapiro when you do you get
this amazing deal
save 50 off your first month which means
that again you'll be spending like ten
bucks a month for your first month again
that is pound two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro and slash that
cell phone bill
down to the bone and have the same exact
coverage it really is fantastic pure
talk usa
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro and say
off your first month when you do
alrighty so
the media have been attempting to spin
this thing and spin it they have the new
york times
headlined they tweeted this out quote
senator kamala harris of california
is joe biden's pick for vice president a
pragmatic moderate
she's the first black woman on a major
party ticket well the only sentence
the only part of that sentence that
matters to the new york times is as
we'll see the last part of that sentence
that she's the first black woman on a
major party ticket i don't think this
has the same quite historic appeal
you know black woman on a major party
ticket as barack obama first black
president for two terms i think we have
already established in the united states
that we are willing to elect black
people to extraordinarily high office
kamala harris is not breaking any glass
ceilings here because there was no glass
ceiling
hillary clinton was last major party
nominee she won the popular vote so
we've already had a woman
who won the most popular votes in the
presidential election and we've already
had a two-term black president
so the notion that kamala harris faces
unique obstacles is
absolutely ridiculous in fact she faces
such non-unique obstacles that she could
flame out so dramatically as a candidate
she didn't even last to the first
primary and then she can get selected
specifically because she checks certain
intersectional boxes
this is not the story of a woman who
earned her way to the vp nomination
okay she completely blew herself up and
it didn't matter
because the media clamored for
particular boxes to be checked and thus
the boxes were checked is she a
pragmatic moderate of course she's not a
pragmatic moderate
but the new york times is is doing the
full-on drool cup routine
their front page is just astonishing i
mean
their front page today is just created
handcrafted
in kamala harris's third bedroom in her
guesthouse it's amazing they've got the
full-on hero picture of kamala harris
she's crossing her arms
she's looking into the distance che
guevara style
it's really it's really a beautiful
photo the giant headline says harris
joins biden ticket achieving a first
and then there are three more headlines
here are the f here are the three more
headlines you ready for this
political warrior shaped by life in two
worlds
wow a political warrior shaped by life
in two worlds pick seen as safe but
energizing uh safe
and also energizing why that's as good
as it gets it's both safe
and energizing i mean it's like
energizer bunny but also
it's safe incredible okay and then
there's this headline
woman of color in number two slot of
major party wow
unbelievable groundbreaking we yes we
had a black president for for two terms
we did and we had a woman who won the
most popular votes but women of color in
the number two slot
of a major party wow wow historic by the
way
this is a pretty great country is it not
yeah i've been told that opportunities
are not available to people of color
kamala harris is the daughter of a
jamaican immigrant and an
indian-american immigrant
and she rose through the ranks to become
a senator from california and then was
selected as vice president of the united
states
seems like a pretty great life seems
like there's a pretty damned great
country
that she will then set about her mind to
to talk about how terrible it is
okay but so the media are just they've
got the drool cups full out
for kamala harris david axelrod says
she's the safest pick
the adviser to barack obama obama
himself was very thrilled
with the kamala harris pick i'm old
enough to remember when
barack obama said some kind of sexist
things about her looks actually back in
the day
in any case cnn's david axelrod he says
it is a measure of these extraordinary
times that joe biden's historic choice
for vice president was also the most
conventional
in choosing kamala harris biden selected
the candidate who had been the front
runner among political handicappers and
betting markets for months the senator
from california fulfills biden's pledge
to name a woman
and responds to the expectation that he
would pick the first woman of color ever
to serve
on a national ticket pressure to make
such a choice had been building since
the killing of george floyd et cetera et
cetera et cetera
harris is a charismatic and telegenic
politician okay so this is where it is
pretty obvious that
that david axelrod has been taking joe
rogan's advice and trying dmt
harris is a charismatic and telegenic
politician
really is she is she now
i mean i suppose she's magnetic on
television in the same way that joaquin
phoenix is magnetic in that scene
from joker where he goes on the late
night show and then proceeds to laugh
like hysterical crazy person
as a u.s senator and recent presidential
candidate harris also meets another
important test for biden people familiar
with
research research the campaign undertook
to inform its decision
told me voters viewed her as among the
most qualified to be president day one
elizabeth warren's just over in the
corner crying somewhere
by the way the polling numbers like that
are incredibly stupid
they view her as qualified to be
president that's because they know her
name they didn't know the names of any
of the other people
being discussed she is familiar with the
maelstrom of a national campaign says
david
axelrod having spent a year running for
president albeit unsuccessfully
though she was at times less than sure
footed in dealing with incoming
criticism
she understands the pace and nature of
it which will only intensify in a fall
race
against trump yes i'm i'm sure it's
it's amazing apparently everybody in the
media have the have the
memory span of a guppy and they're all
like dory from from finding nemo they
don't remember five minutes ago when
tulsi gabbard finished her on the stage
i mean absolutely brutalized her
so president trump for his part he
reacted he said i'm glad that joe picked
kamala harris
he is correct he should be glad that joe
picked kamala harris now he gets to turn
this into a
trump versus harris campaign which is a
much better campaign for him
it's been difficult for him to attack
joe biden because again joe biden is
basically a dead person joe biden is a
corpse it is difficult to attack a
corpse
but now because it appears that joe
biden has picked a radical as his vp
candidate and because joe biden is a
corpse trump should just go right around
biden
he should joe biden was ignored for most
of his political career because he's a
career politician with no particular
skills to recommend him he was ignored
in
1 000 presidential campaigns before and
then he was obama's vp it's only his
association with others that has made
joe biden in any way an important figure
in washington dc
and right now it is very obvious i mean
joe biden himself has said that he is a
transitional figure
so trump should just treat him that way
he should treat him the same way that
most americans treat the washington
football team's new name
in fact i think the washington football
team should rename itself the washington
bidens
in honor of the fact that it's an
interim name that means nothing and will
be gone
incredibly soon here is president trump
saying he is glad that joe
biden picked kamala harris again he
should be
she was my number one pick i mean she
was like as they would say
because hopefully you'll start college
well she was my number one
draft pick and we'll see how she works
out
she did very very poorly in the
primaries as you know she was expected
to do well
and she was she ended up at
right around two percent and spent a lot
of money
she had a lot of things happening and so
i was a little surprised that he picked
her
fact check true fact check true trump
then suggested that she is nasty and
disrespectful which of course is going
to launch a thousand headlines about how
it's sexist to point out that kamala
harris is actually
quite cruel which she absolutely is
we'll talk about in just one moment not
just to
small tournament children but apparently
also to the person
who she's now running with okay we're
gonna get to that in just a moment here
was trump going after harris yesterday
she's got a lot of difficult things that
she's going to
have to explain plus she was very very
nasty
to one of the reasons that surprised me
she was very she was probably nastier
than
even pocahontas to joe biden
she was very disrespectful to joe biden
and it's hard to pick somebody that's
that disrespectful when
she said things during the debates
during the
democrat primary debates that were
horrible okay well he is absolutely
right about
that we'll get to the campaign ad that
the trump campaign immediately released
as soon as kamala harris was named the
pick
but first if you have a car that's
taking up space sitting in your driveway
why would you not get rid of it you're
paying insurance on that thing and you
could do something
amazing with that car donate it to cars
for kids many of you have heard that
jingle
you know the one that you know right the
one that i'm gonna sing right now it's
gonna be stuck in your head the rest of
the day you ready for it
one eight seven seven cars for kids
k-a-r-s
cars for kids now it's stuck in your
head the rest of your life well
it will be until you give your car to
cars for kids you get a tax deduction
and a vacation voucher here's how it
works
cars for kids makes the process of
donating your car quick and easy it
takes just about two minutes they handle
all the details all the paperwork all
you need to do is schedule a pickup and
sign the title your car donation is fast
and free it's usually picked up within
24 hours
often even the same day cars for kids
will take your car even if it is not
running
donating your car is tax deductible your
tax deduction is based on the sale price
of your car
cars for kids works hard to sell your
car for the best price which means more
funds for their charity and a bigger tax
deduction for you
as a special thank you for donating your
car cars for kids gives you a vacation
voucher good for a three day and two
night hotel stay so this is a pretty
awesome deal with cars for kids you get
a professional service
a convenient pickup a maximum tax
deduction a vacation voucher
and a good deed donate today at
carsforkids.org
shapiro that's cars with a k k-a-r-s the
number four
kids dot org slash ben k-a-r-s-4-k-i-d-s
org ben will give you the donation
experience you deserve
cars4kids.org ben that's cars4kids.org
ben the trump campaign has now put out
an ad
immediately upon joe biden naming kamala
harris here was the trump campaign ad it
is indeed an effective ad
kamala harris ran for president by
rushing to the radical left
embracing bernie's plan for socialized
medicine calling for trillions of new
taxes
attacking joe biden for racist policies
voters rejected harris
they smartly spotted a phony but not joe
biden
he's not that smart biden calls himself
a transition candidate
he is handing over the reins to kamala
while they jointly embrace the radical
left
slo joe and phony kamala perfect
together
wrong for america so he's gonna need to
do better than phony commonwealth
because i don't think that that
it's the the question about kamala
harris is not that she is a phony the
question about kamala harris is that she
is
an extraordinarily radical candidate who
is indeed manipulative
i would be going trojan horse harris i
mean pretty obvious trojan horse harris
right i mean that biden is not even
he like they're wheeling him around on a
gurney at this point
and as soon like kamala harris is just
like just make it to j
just make it to january joe just make it
to january joe just make it to january
joe
that's what the democratic party is
basically praying for at
this point now let's go through a little
bit of kamala harris's history because i
think it's important to recognize the
way that her
career took shape right this is this is
a person who
is basically willing to say or do
anything to get power but who also has
extraordinarily strong authoritarian
tendencies
she is very very extreme and all this is
fair game
okay before everybody starts shouting
that that you're not allowed to talk
about kamala harris's past she's running
for vice president of the united states
it was fair game when she was running
for senate it was fair game when she was
running for president it is fair game
now that she's the vice presidential
nominee
on a major party ticket okay so it is
absolutely fair game to ask
how she started her career and donald
trump is not going to be shy about
mentioning this
a 1994 la times report about then
california assembly speaker willie
brown's
rushed to hand out patronage jobs
described kamala harris as brown's
frequent companion
and said several people's referred to
her as brown's girlfriend
okay that report also cited a column
from the chronicles herbicide and they
called harris the speaker's new study
brown was married at the time willie
brown is the most powerful people in
california
he was 60 she was 29 so it was a love
match according to kane the couple split
up in 1995 which flabbergasted those who
found kamala the perfect antidote to
whatever playboy tendencies still reside
in the mayor alex jaunty persona he
ended up as the mayor of san francisco
although brown supported harris in her
successful 2003 run for san francisco
district attorney she tried to distance
herself
from him in that race telling san
francisco weekly that brown whose career
was then dogged by corruption
allegations was an albatross hanging
around my neck
his career is over i will be alive and
kicking for the next 40 years i do not
owe him a thing
she told san francisco weekly and this
is pretty typical kamala harris right so
she dates the guy when she's 29 and he's
60. he gives her a bunch of patronage
positions
and then as soon as she's running for da
in san francisco she's like i've never
heard of him he's a bad man i think he's
corrupt
brown wrote yes i may have influenced
her career by appointing her to two
state commissions when i was assembly
speaker
he was the speaker of the assembly from
80 to 95.
brown appointed harris to the california
unemployment insurance appeals board
and then to the medical assistance
commission positions that paid her more
than 400
000 over five years he also gave her a
bmw
he said i certainly helped her win her
first race for district attorney in san
francisco
i have also helped the careers of house
speaker nancy pelosi gavin newsom and
dianne feinstein he added the difference
is that harris is the only one who after
i helped her sent word i would be
indicted if i so much as jaywalked while
she was d.a brown wrote that's politics
for you
uh kamala harris what a what a charmer
okay but
kamal harris then became a district
attorney
in san francisco and then on the basis
of that she ran for attorney general
in california and there she campaigned
as a hardcore
law and order type and she said that she
was going to go after criminals and
listen
i'm a big fan of going after criminals
but she simultaneously
went after very very low level offenders
and also basically did nothing to lower
the crime rates in california which is
kind of an amazing achievement when you
think about it
kamala harris according to lara bazelon
the director of the criminal
juvenile justice and racial justice
clinical programs writing in the new
york times
said consider her record as san
francisco district attorney from 2004 to
ms harris was criticized in 2010 for
withholding information about a police
laboratory technician who'd been accused
of intentionally sabotaging her work
and stealing drugs from the lab after a
memo surfaced showing that harris's
deputies knew about the technician's
wrongdoing and recent conviction but
failed to alert defense lawyers a judge
condemned harris's indifference to the
systemic
violation of the defendant's
constitutional rights harris contested
the ruling
arguing that the judge whose husband was
a defense attorney had a conflict of
interest
harris lost and more than 600 cases
handled by the corrupt technician
were dismissed she also famously decided
that she was going to support
a law that allowed for the prosecution
of parents
for truancy of children in 2004 harris
and then san francisco mayor gavin
newsom who's now the governor of
california
launched an anti-truancy initiative the
450 000
program included a warning to parents
they could face a criminal charge if
their kids didn't show up to school
to be considered true a student needed
to be only 30 minutes late without an
unapproved excuse on more than two
occasions
parents of students with 20 or more
unexcused absences in a year
could face a year in jail or a 2500 fine
and then she laughed about it
and then she laughed about that like
openly
to so that that was her stick her
was that she was going to be
the tough on crime candidate and this
has led obviously to
a lot of consternation among radical
left types about her being a cop
and frankly i think some of that
consternation is warranted i mean she
endorsed
she endorsed legislation that would
allow for the confiscation of private
assets before a prosecution
before a prosecution took place she
she backed civil asset forfeiture before
any of the civil uh before any of the
prosecutions had actually
been legalized at that point so she was
willing to use the authority of the
government
to do pretty much anything which is very
much in line with with kamala harris's
thinking
and then obviously when she was running
for president then it became totally
okay to joke about past marijuana use
right so she prosecuted
like a thousand people 1500 people for
marijuana use
which again like if you're as a strict
law and order guy if you're a drug
dealer and it gets downgraded to a
marijuana use charge and you go to jail
i don't have a problem with that but
you certainly don't get to laugh about
smoking pot at the same time that you're
talking about
how you were a great prosecutor here was
kamala harris laughing
at her own marijuana use
okay but she actually went on a podcast
where she laughed about her own
marijuana use this led tulsi gabbard to
famously wreck
harris during a debate pointing out that
kamala harris was the queen of tough on
crime
and then laughed and scoffed about her
own marijuana use at exactly the same
time basically
senator harris says she's proud of her
record as a prosecutor and that she'll
be a prosecutor president but i'm deeply
concerned about this record
there are too many examples to cite but
she put over 1500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana
she blocked evidence she blocked
evidence
that would have freed an innocent man
from death row until the courts forced
her to do so
she kept people in prison beyond their
sentences to use them as cheap labor for
the state of california
and she fought to keep cash bail system
in place
that impacts poor people in the worst
kind of way
and harris was attacked like this twice
in debate and had no answer to it
anywhere
along the line which is why it's no
shock that brianna joy gray
who is the former national press
secretary for bernie sanders
labeled harris as america's quote
unquote top cop
right so so she's going to be attacked
from the left for being too harsh on
crime but she's only harsh on crime
on on a low level really because she
wanted
to be perceived that way so that she
could then run a senator
because being a democratic prosecutor
always makes you look better when you
run for senator then as soon as she
became senator
she swiveled to the extraordinarily
radical left by the way at the same time
that she was being tough on crime she
was cultivating the banks she was
cultivating
silicon valley apparently silicon valley
is super duper pleased that kamala
harris has now
been chosen according to recode cooper
tebow
a former democratic fundraiser a top
democratic fundraiser in silicon valley
said about one-third of major west coast
donors have been waiting to see who
biden would choose as vp
if biden had chosen warren they would
have had concerns but they said that
kamala harris is a safe pick
so very tough on the prosecutions of the
marijuana
but pretty tight with all the people in
in power so that pretty much
it confirms what we think about about
kamal harris we'll get to her actual
authoritarian streak in just one second
because she has a strong authoritarian
streak
first let's talk about getting in shape
now getting in shape doesn't have to be
about losing a specific
amount of weight or a magic number on
the scale it's about building a
healthier lifestyle and this is why i
have been so overjoyed to use nume you
may have noticed i'm looking more svelte
these days in fact
over the past few months really since
the beginning of the pandemic
i've dropped somewhere between 15 and 20
pounds i've done a lot of that
simply by using num to help monitor my
habits and change my habits each and
every day noom is the habit changing
solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses based in
psychology neum teaches you why you do
the things you do and empowers you with
the tools you need to break bad habits
and replace them with better ones
no food is good bad or off-limits noom
teaches moderation can be used in
conjunction with many pre-existing
popular diets if you want
neum doesn't tell you what to do and
what not to do it teaches you how to
look inside your own mind and make
better decisions for yourself
numa has one of the biggest most
accurate food databases available that
lets you track meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance
you can chat with your goal specialist
in neum community and get and give help
to people going through the same things
it really forms a sense of community it
really is fantastic i've recommended it
to my own parents
you don't have to change it all in one
day small steps make big progress sign
up for your trial today
at noon that's n-o-o-m dot com shapiro
got nothing to lose visit new dot com
slash appear to start that trial today
that's n-o-o-m.com
shapiro go check them out right now if
it worked for me it can work for you as
well they make it really easy
noom.com shapiro okay so
what do we learn from kamala harris's
tenure well we learned that she's
incredibly manipulative that she will
use people to get ahead and then she
will ditch them at the first available
opportunity
as we'll see she did this to joe biden
as well and she will ditch him at first
available opportunity
as well too we know that she is
perfectly willing to use the auspices of
government in order to achieve
particular goals
she's willing to be authoritarian in her
use of government and she's threatened
to be incredibly authoritarian if ever
she became president
during this last campaign she repeatedly
talked about how she was going to
overthrow the boundaries of
constitutional government
like all the time she said openly that
she would give congress 100 days to act
on guns
and then if congress did not act on guns
then she would immediately
use executive action to act on guns so
this is her openly threatening to
violate the constitution if congress
doesn't do there is no clause in the
constitution by the way that says
if congress doesn't do what the
president wants the executive branch
shall have the powers to simply declare
the law
there's nothing in the constitution like
that but as we'll see kamala harris does
not give two good dams about the
constitution
because that's who she is here is kamala
harris in open debate
saying that she'd give congress 100 days
tacked on guns then she'd just do it
herself
upon being elected i will give the
united states congress
100 days to get their act together and
have the courage
to pass reasonable gun safety laws and
if they fail to do it
then i will take executive action and
specifically what i will do
is put in place a requirement that for
anyone who sells more than five guns a
year
they are required to do background
checks when they sell those guns
amazing amazing so she's just gonna do
it herself and then when she was asked
about this in open debate
right joe biden was like um that's
unconstitutional kamala like there's a
lot of stuff you can't just do
as president of the united states and
kamala hair is like well yes we can
hyena like joke or laugh okay so by the
way
like it's i guess it's good that she was
cast as vp because otherwise she would
have been the heir apparent for for the
joker part
right jared leto was out already so the
next suicide squad would have been
kamala harris laughing with that crazy
caesar romero kind of giggle here she
was
trying to explain to joe biden that the
constitution is hacked needed no longer
matters and joe biden's standing there
but i remember the constitution i was
there when they when they wrote it i've
been ignoring it for
and then he fell asleep here this was
from a democratic debate you can't do it
by executive order
any more than trump can do things when
he says he can do it by executive order
does the vice president have a point
there
some things you can many things you
can't let's let the senator answer
oh i mean i would just say hey joe
instead of saying no we can't let's say
yes we can
let's be constitutional
[Laughter]
yeah looking forward to a lot of that
looking forward to a lot of that get
ready
you got a lot of that that crazy laugh
yeah good stuff happening there so she's
an authoritarian who can laugh crazily
so that's that's exciting stuff by the
way she also supports packing the
supreme court so that's good
definitely somebody who is a pragmatic
moderate according to the new york times
harris told politico quote we are on the
verge of a crisis of confidence in the
supreme court
we have to take this challenge head on
everything is on the table to do that
so she joined with and kirsten
gillibrand
and elizabeth warren saying that she
might consider packing at the courts
she's definitely a moderate guys
definitely definitely moderate
okay and then there is kamala harris the
opportunist so as we talked about
rather opportunistic in her early career
okay but she's been even more
opportunistic on issues of race
so very early on uh in this race she
she basically recognizing that her main
pitch for the presidency
was the intersectional check marks on
her resume she
complained that people should not say
anything about identity policy that
identity politics is good
don't worry she's a moderate who will
bring americans together but identity
politics is good it's a way to
anybody who complains about it is just
trying to shut us up no i want her to
laugh more i want more of that charming
graceful laugh from kamala harris i
think it's beautiful i think it's a
beautiful sound
anybody who doesn't think that that
sound is beautiful is simply being
misogynistic
here was kamala harris talking about how
identity politics
have been are good they are they're an
active affirmative good
term identity politics people will
use that term it's like people used to
talk about the race card
right and they'll bring this term up
when you talk about issues that are
about race
about sexual orientation about religion
they'll bring it up when we're talking
about civil rights issues
as a way to marginalize the issue as a
way to frankly
try to silence you or shut you up okay
no one's shutting up kamala harris she's
been fully able to talk for
literally her entire life i mean
basically since she was a child she's
been able to talk
and it seems like nobody has really been
successful in uh enforcing her into
saying anything or not saying
anything in fact she's been able to say
anything and everything she wants to say
including some of the dumbest crap
that's ever entered the human lexicon
here's kamala harris tweeting back in
january 2019
you'll remember that there was a victim
of a hate crime named jesse smallette
unfortunately his victimizer was also a
man named jesse smallette jesse smallett
suggested that there are two white men
wearing red maga hats basically
walking down the street at 3 a.m in
chicago in the middle of a of a freezing
wind storm
who decided to hit him with bleach and
then put a rope around his neck and
it all ended up being bull crap which
was perfectly obvious it was from
basically the first moments kamala
harris however jumped in at the time
and tweeted out jesse smolyer is one of
the kindest most gentle human beings i
know i'm praying for his quick recovery
this was an attempt in modern day
lynching by the way the tweet is still
up
no one should have to fear for their
life because of their sexuality or color
of their skin we must confront
this hate and uh you know it's true i
mean jesse smallette did commit a hate
crime against jesse smallette
and kamala harris was very upset about
it at the time it was a modern day
lynching
by jesse smellette against jesse salette
kamala harris is an incredibly
incredibly cynical politician how
cynical is she well
she has now decided to sign on to the
campaign of a man that she called
essentially a segregationist and perhaps
also a sexual abuser that is kamala
harris don't worry she's not an
opportunist in any way
she is merely a sincere pragmatic
moderate
a sincere pragmatic model you have
nothing to fear from the
manipulative opportunistic authoritarian
radical
com nothing to fear guys nothing to fear
she was the safest possible pet
we're going to get to more of kamala
harris opportunist in just one second
first let's talk about the fact now
terrible time to go to the post office
and not only is it a terrible time
why would you anyway you can get special
deals right now on the cost
of your stamps on the cost of your
postage you can get incredible deals
right now at stamps.com that save you
tremendous amounts of time
and money thousands of small business
owners have discovered the benefits of
stamps.com
in recent months they've been able to
keep their businesses running and avoid
the crowds at the post office all from
their
home computers or office computers with
stamps.com you can print postage on
demand you can avoid heading over to the
post office
and you save money with discounted rates
you can't even get at the post office
stamps.com also offers ups services with
discounts up to 62 percent
no residential surcharges here's
dailywear we've been using stamps.com
since 2017 which is one of the reasons
why
we are a highly profitable media empire
stamps.com brings all the mailing and
shipping services you need
directly to your computer in the comfort
of your home or office whether you're a
small business sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products
or you're just working from home you
need to mail stuff in stamps.com can
handle it all
with ease and as i say with stamps.com
you get amazing discounts five cents off
every stamp
62 off you usps and ups shipping rates
it is a
no-brainer go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro and you get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and digital scale
no long-term commitments just go to
stamps.com enter shapiro
go check it out right now stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage or type in shapiro save
money the same way that i do at home
same way that we do here at
dailywirestamps.com
for the best possible rates best
possible prices save yourself tons of
time
stamps.com click on that mic at the top
of the page type in shapiro
okay before we get to more of the
charming and moderate
kamala harris and we're about to get to
what kamohara said about uh joe biden
during this campaign
basically she now says that she is going
to run on the same ticket as a
quasi-segregationist would have kept her
out of integrated schools and a person
who routinely uh sexually harasses women
but she she's very principled guys very
principled we'll get to that in a second
first
i need to tell you about our most
exclusive membership tier over at daily
wire
all access all access members get to
join alexis live that's our exclusive
live stream q as
hosted every night by each of the hosts
including myself this thursday august
13th for example
i will be hosting an all access live
we'll be discussing my new book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
which has been at the top of the charts
since it was released
in july i've gotten a lot of amazing
feedback we've got questions from you
our readers so this thursday night i'll
be taking questions and discussing some
of the themes ideas etc
in the book with all of you all access
members we'll also possibly be reading
rap lyrics apparently this is a very
popular thing that i do
and yes my cover of that awful cardi b
song is better than the original
i mean listen skill sets i didn't even
know i had all access membership also
features exclusive access to live online
discussions with our hosts
writers and special guests along with
not one but two
count them two leftist years tumblr with
your membership as well as early
sometimes exclusive access
to new daily wire products you saw that
last week with our limited account
collectors edition baseball bat
available only
to all access members you missed out if
you weren't an all access member it sold
out less than 48 hours
head on over right now to dailywire.com
shapiro you get 20
off all access with coupon code access
you can also get my book how to destroy
america in three easy steps
at amazon or barnes and noble if you
want to join the discussion remember
dailywire.com
shapiro with coupon code access to get
20 off your membership you are listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
absolutely opportunistic kamala harris
willing to say or do
literally anything to get ahead
and and all you have to do is point to
the comments you made about joe biden by
the way
some of us are consistent i defended joe
biden against this garbage scurrilous
attack
back when she originally levied it
against him so
you'll remember all the way back at the
beginning of this campaign there's
democratic debate
this little teddy tet sent kamala harris
rocketing to the top of the polls
because everyone is stupid
and everyone is dishonest essentially
kamala harris called joe biden
segregationist she said if it were
if joe biden had had his way then little
kamal a little little baby kamala never
would have been able to go to an
integrated public school
in san francisco except for the fact
that she
obviously would have and um and joe
biden was not opposed to integration
and um it was all a lie and she doesn't
support forced bussing but it was this
magical attack that made kamala harris's
name on the national stage because this
lady is willing to say or do anything
she will savage anyone to get ahead here
she was going after the guy who would
later select her as vp because he's a
daughtering old fool
it's personal and it was actually very
it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country
and it was not only that but
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bused to school every day
and that little girl was me okay and
then she started selling for 30 bucks a
pop that little girl was me t-shirts
like within moments it was a pre-planned
attack on the guy who would later select
her svp
calling him a racist okay so the media
are going into full spin mode on this
because this is not the same thing as
ronald reagan picking george
h.w bush after hw suggested that
reaganomics was voodoo economics that's
a disagreement on policy
right that would be the same thing as
biden picking harris and
them having disagreements on medicare
for all right which is the thing i mean
that's true
that's not quite the same thing as
someone calls you an overt racist who is
going to stop her from going
to an integrated school when she was a
child okay that's what she did there
and all the revisionist history in the
world ain't gonna fix that okay she is
now running
what an opportunist she's running on the
same ticket as a man that she called a
segregationist essentially
and then she doubled down on it she said
that biden should apologize for ever
having said any kind words about any
senator whoever was a segregationist
and she demanded that apology and in
fact when asked if biden should drop
out of the race okay she was like well
that's up to him
what what an honorable honorable deeply
honorable candidate i mean i wouldn't
fear her in a position of power at all
this lady
to coddle the reputations of
segregationists
of people who if they had their way i
would literally not be standing here as
a member of the united states senate
is i think um it's just it's misinformed
and it's wrong
should joe apologize for that he's gonna
have to make that decision
but you know let's be very clear that
the the senators that he is speaking
of with such adoration are individuals
who
made and built their reputation on
segregation
okay so um yeah that's who she was and
by the way she didn't stop there
when kamala harris was asked during this
campaign because she was desperate to
win i mean desperate to get any sort of
traction at all she had none
she was like wheels skidding on ice
throughout this campaign
when she was asked about the accusers
who came forward and said joe biden is
weird and creepy and smells people's
hairs and and touches them in
inappropriate ways
cumberland harris is like yeah i believe
the accusers so she's now running
on the ticket with a with with a
guy who she literally called
a quasi segregationist who sexually
harasses women regularly
but don't worry she loves him and they
are best friends and also she's not an
opportunist in any way she's just a
deeply honest
politician of conviction i believe
them and i i respect
them being able to tell their story and
having the courage to do it
do you believe that the vice president
should enter this race
oh he's gonna have to make that decision
for himself i wouldn't tell him what to
do
oh yeah i wouldn't tell him what to do
but you know if he if if he dropped out
that'd be great
that's not the same thing as vice
presidents and presidents having general
conflicts of views that is her basically
insinuating that joe biden
is a a horrible human being
right so that was kamala harris but the
good news for joe biden is that he is
not the only target of her tender
mercies
you'll remember when kamala harris
essentially implied
that justice brett kavanaugh was a
rapist in fact during the
hearings on on brett kavanaugh she went
in a cloak room and handed to
republicans an anonymous letter accusing
brett kavanaugh of rape
it was signed by a woman named jane doe
right meaning just anonymous person
it contained no details whatsoever and
it was used as the basis for questioning
because that's who kamala harris is here
was kamal harris going after brett
kavanaugh asking him if he had taken a
polygraph
pushing an fbi investigation and and
then when he's
one of kavanaugh's lines of defense was
here are a bunch of women who have
treated incredibly well throughout my
career
and kamala harris was like well is it
true that you can be friends with some
women and treat other women badly
she's just she's so cynical and so awful
and she
she's a bad person here here's kamala
harris being a bad person
judge kavanaugh have you taken a
professionally administered polygraph
test i've not heard you answer a very
specific question that's been asked
which is are you willing to ask the
white house
to conduct an investigation by the fbi
to get to whatever you believe is the
bottom of the allegations that have been
levied against you do you agree that it
is possible
for men to both be friends
with some women and treat other women
badly
this was this was touted by the media as
an extraordinary showing
by comment by the way that wasn't even
the worst thing she did during the
comment during the kavanaugh hearings
kavanaugh hearings is she somehow she
threw out a bizarre theory
that brett kavanaugh was working with a
law firm called kasowitz that was also
working with the trump administration
against the mueller investigation
and so somehow for some unnamed reason
kavanaugh
was obstructing the mueller
investigation or something she kind of
threw this out there it created a bevy
of headlines and then
she never followed up on it because
that's what she does that's what she
does
she uses anything at hand in order to
harm her political opposition no matter
how dishonestly she has to
no matter how dishonest she has to be
here she was going after brett kavanaugh
for some weird theory about
him sharing a law firm with with members
of the trump administration
have you discussed mueller or his
investigation with anyone at kasowitz
benson and torres the law firm founded
by mark kasowitz
president trump's personal lawyer
uh be sure about your answer sir
is there a person you're talking about
i'm asking you a very direct question
yes or no
who'd you talk to you have an impeccable
memory you've been speaking for
almost eight hours i think more with
this committee about all sorts of things
you remember
how can you not remember whether or not
you had
a conversation about robert mueller
or his investigation with anyone at that
law firm
she literally never explained what the
hell she meant by this at all
this made huge headlines at the time
right she was going to uncover
be careful of your answer sir she was
going to uncover the conspiracy
she was going to uncover a conspiracy
whereby brett kavanaugh was somehow
conferring behind closed doors with a
law firm
that was representing trump in the
mueller like nothing ever came of this
because she's a bad human being okay
when you throw out
allegations like this in open in open
questioning of a supreme court nominee
with no support whatsoever and then you
just kind of like it just disappears
into the ether
it is amazing amazing that this person
is considered a credible politician on
the national stage
none of this by the way even touches her
political radicalism some a lot of this
goes to character she's an authoritarian
by nature
she's an opportunist by nature and she's
willing to say or do anything to get
ahead
okay that is perfectly obvious
throughout her career as somebody from
california she's been my senator for
quite a while she was my ag
okay this is somebody who is willing to
to
pursue any policy that she thinks is
going to bring her power
okay which brings us to what she would
actually do with the power her actual
views on a variety of issues are
extraordinarily radical she's no
pragmatic moderate she's nowhere near
the middle of the political spectrum
she's extensively radical
extraordinarily radical
i don't know if you remember this one
she's she's extremely anti-catholic
alexander desantis writing at national
review reminds
reminds everybody that in late 2018
while evaluating the nomination of brian
boucher to serve as a district judge
in nebraska harris posed a series of
questions insinuating that his
involvement in the knights of columbus a
charitable catholic fraternal
organization disqualified him from
serving on the bench
one of her written questions was since
1993 you have been a member of the
knights of columbus an all-male society
comprised primarily of catholic men
in 2016 carl anderson leader of the
knights of columbus described abortion
as a legal regime
that had that has resulted in more than
40 million deaths anderson went on to
say abortion is the killing of the
innocent on a mass scale
were you aware the knights of columbus
opposed a woman's right to choose when
he joined the organization
she then went on to ask boucher whether
he was aware the knights of columbus
opposed marriage equality when he joined
or whether he had ever in any way
assisted with or contributed to advocacy
against women's reproductive rights okay
that's a catholic the knights of
columbus is a catholic group with
millions of members
it's an important charity and she was
basically saying that because you're a
catholic you shouldn't be on the bench
because that's who kamala harris is
kamala harris is the same person who
filed an amicus brief in hobby lobby
arguing that religious practice should
basically be relegated to the home
in her amicus brief terence jeffries
pointed this out at the time
she argued quote rights to the free
exercise of religious beliefs whether
created by statute or by the
constitution
likewise protect the development and
expression of an inner sanctum of
personal religious faith
free exercise rights have thus also been
understood as a personal
as personal relating only to individual
believers and to a limited class of
associations comprising or representing
them
there is no tradition of recognizing or
accommodating the exercise of such
inherently personal rights by ordinary
for-profit business corporations in
other words
if you operate in the business fear we
are going to completely override your
religious rights
that is the legal regime that kamal
harris seeks
she says it would be better to keep the
free exercise of religion within the
boundaries of religious institutions
she says the term religion itself
connotes a community of believers
religious organizations act as critical
buffers between the individual and the
power of the state
giving individuals a space to which to
in which to exercise faith without state
intrusion in other words maybe she'll
make an exception
for some of the for some of the
religious organizations don't count on a
gang
do not count on it she she is not going
to allow religious believers to operate
their businesses in accordance with
their actual religious scruples
it's not just that on abortion she's
extraordinarily radical extremely
radical
in fact she had a proposal modeled on
the voting rights act of 1965 that would
require
any state with a history of passing laws
restricting abortion access
to get clearance pre-clearance from the
justice department so kamala harris
would force the state of alabama
to run any law that affects abortion by
kamala harris's doj
before passing the law which violates
all precepts of federalism
like all precepts of federalism
i mean it's pretty incredible so that
she by the way she is so radical on
abortion that she voted a lot
she voted against she's one of many
democrats in fact every democratic
presidential candidate to vote against
the born alive infant protection act
that's an act that was specifically
designed to prevent infanticide
okay she voted against that
it's it's pretty amazing ben sasse was
the chief sponsor he said i want to ask
each and every one of my colleagues
whether or not we're okay
with infanticide he said this is about
the most simple thing you can say which
is that a baby is a baby and they have
dignity and worth
it's not because they're powerful it's
because they're babies today's a sad day
in the united states
didn't matter kamala harris voted
against it because she's a radical
on abortion she also happens to be a
radical on immigration in an open
hearing
she associated ice right immigrations
and customs enforcement with the kkk
here was here is kamala harris doing
just that
i do not see a parallel between what is
constitutionally mandated
as as it relates to enforcing the law
are you aware that there's a perception
are you aware that there's a perspective
ice in the same category as the kkk
is that what you're asking me no i'm
very specific about what i'm asking
are you aware of a perception that the
way
that the discretion i see i'm not
finished i see none
i'm not finished i'm not finished are
you aware that there's a perception
that that ice is administering
its power in a way that is causing fear
unbelievable okay this is the same lady
who says that by the way all illegal
immigrants should receive medicare so we
should pay for the entire medical
burden of anybody who comes to the
country illegally she said this to jake
tapper during the race don't worry she's
not a radical guy she's a pragmatic
moderate
i keep saying it over and over why don't
you believe me that she's a pragmatic
moderate i mean who are you gonna
believe
me or the words coming out of kamala
harris's face
every individual who is a resident of
the united states is entitled to
benefits for health care services under
this act
not every individual who's a citizen but
every individual who's a resident
so you support giving universal
healthcare medicare for all to people
who are in this country illegally
let me just be very clear about this i
am opposed to any policy
that would deny in our country any human
being
from access to public safety
public education or public health period
okay and where is she on public health
by the way so she was original endorser
of bernie sanders medicare for all
then she realized it was unpopular and
later she moved to a transitional plan
whereby everybody would lose their
private insurance inside of 10 years
when she was in her early phase right
her radical phase trying to cut off
trying to cut off elizabeth warren on
her left she openly said that we would
phase out private insurance that would
ban private insurance in the united
states
you know the insurance that represents
what 90 of the american public
uh certainly in the private sector so
here is kamala harris saying that she
would phase out private healthcare
don't worry pragmatic moderate guys
pragmatic moderate
i believe the solution and i'm and i'm
actually feel very strongly about this
is that we need to have medicare for all
and you don't have to go through the
process of going through an insurance
company
having them give you approval going
through the paperwork all of the delay
that may require
who of us has not had that situation
where you got to wait for approval and
the doctor says well
i don't know if your insurance company
is going to cover this let's eliminate
all of that let's move on
let's move on from private insurance
let's move on moderate okay by the way
this lady's going to be president
she's going to be president you vote for
joe biden he becomes president she is
the president
that is the unspoken truce here
everybody understands it
every single person and don't believe it
when the media start with the
how dare you question joe biden's mental
fitness or his ability to serve out his
term he's gonna be 78
in november 78 in november
but it doesn't stop there okay let's
talk more about kamala harris's
radicalism
okay so she was asked on the view how
she felt about aoc
i saw aoc and the green new deal and her
plans and she specifically asked
about a 70 top tax rate which by the way
is insane
if you want to destroy every major
business in the united states definitely
implement a 70
top tax rate people will just stop
working to avoid those taxes because
why the hell would you do an additional
10 hours of work a week when seven cents
out of that
out of that 10 is going directly to the
federal government
and that doesn't count the state
government right that means that in the
state of california where we have a 16
17 percent top tax rate
or will within very short order things
13 now you'd be talking about paying
what 83 percent
of your of your money above a certain
point here was kamala harrison it's a
great idea we should invest it don't
worry guys
not a radical a pragmatic moderate it
was her being a pragmatic moderate
endorsing the idea of investigating a 70
top tax rate
and she's promoting policies like saying
that every single carbon emission in the
country every car
should be eliminated within the next 11
years everything from a 70 to 80
tax rate do you agree that she could
possibly in this ideology of the
socialist
left could splinter your party no you
know
i think that um she is
challenging the status quo i think
that's fantastic
i think i think that she is introducing
bold ideas
that that should be discussed and i
think it's good for the party i frankly
think it's good for the country
let's look at the bold ideas let's look
at all those bold ideas
what are some of the other bold ideas so
she has also endorsed a federal ban on
fracking
so we'll see how this goes for joe biden
in pennsylvania where a lot of jobs are
reliance on fracking by the way
you know somebody is not serious about
global warming when their chief policy
priorities banning fracking
you're not serious about it the single
greatest reason for declining carbon
emissions in the united states is the
rise of natural gas replacing oil and
coal
that is that is the single greatest
rationale for why the united states is
actually the leading the world's leading
decreaser of carbon emissions
over the last five to ten years but here
is kamala harris endorsing a federal ban
on fracking
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking so
yeah and and starting and starting with
what we can do on day one around public
lands right
and um and then there has to be
legislation but yes and this is
something i've taken on in california i
have a history of working on this issue
and to your point
um and you know that we have to just
acknowledge that the residual
impact of fracking is enormous in terms
of the impact on the health and safety
of communities
well i mean yeah fracking is really a
danger to communities like you know all
the communities with hundreds of
thousands of people reliant on the
fracking industry
it's a bold move cotton it's a bold move
also she says that we need to
incentivize americans to eat less meat
so good luck with this i
i think that this is going to go great
for joe biden again
so much moderation just spilling from
the lips of kamala harris here
the balance that we have to strike here
frankly is
about what government can and should do
around creating incentives
and then banning certain behaviors i
mean just to be very honest with you i
love cheeseburgers from time to time
right i mean i i just do and and i think
that um
but there is but there has to be also
what we do in terms of
creating incentives that we will eat in
a healthy way that we will encourage
moderation
and that we will be educated about the
effect of our eating habits
on our environment and we have to do a
much better job of that and the
government has to do a much better job
of that
okay so let's let's let's meet guys also
let's ban plastic straws
she's she will use the government to do
anything anything that's what she said
about plastic
she she's like yeah the plastic
struggles you want to hear some
hysterical camel hairs laughter
it's been like a solid few minutes since
we played kamala harris laughing
hysterically and awkwardly
when she realized that what she's saying
is kind of crazy here is kamala here's
laughing crazily about plastic straws
do you ban plastic straws i think we
should
yes i mean look i'm going to be honest
it's really difficult to drink out of a
paper straw when you had if you're just
like if you don't gulp it down
immediately it starts to bend and then
and then you know the little thing
catches it and then you know
so we got to kind of perfect that one a
little bit more
so you'd ban it but rely on innovation i
mean we got we got it
yeah innovation is it's a process right
you don't just
do it innovation is a process but but
you know let's let's encourage
innovation and and you know
i think we could do a little bit better
than some of those flimsy plastic straws
but we don't need to ban them
hey by the way i do love that that aaron
burnett is
that's aaron burnette correct who's
who's that reporter us
i'm i i believe that taran burnett
correct i don't want to screw up the
name of the uh
of the reporter so i'm going to look
this up just to ensure that i'm correct
yeah that's aaron bernat so aaron so
aaron burnett
i love her just feeding the line to
kamala harris so you're gonna ban
plastic cross but rely on innovation
yeah that's exactly what she was saying
no what actually happened there is that
kamala harris was like i want to ban
plastic straws and then she realized
halfway through
that the replacement straws are absolute
crap and so she's like and but they're
really bad they're placement straws but
i still want to ban them because i'm an
authoritarian jerk
but you know they're really bad and so
aaron burnett's like innovation
innovation like from from off stage left
the line is
innovation and kind of like yeah
innovation but you know it's
it's a process guys i get a bit
man get ready years of that coming up
years years if she wins years
but don't worry if you're concerned that
maybe a lot of this is going to cost
money maybe this is bad policy
we've been reliably informed by kamal
harris that policy is not about cost
guys
policy is not about cost policy is about
the principle behind
the thing here is kamala harris
explaining we should pay no attention
to the fact that things cost money money
is just a figment of your imagination
it's just an idea out there
the really big issue is whether we
should be ambitious
ambitious and hopeful here she was being
like money
what's that why should i care about that
it's not my money let's just do it
policy and cost three trillion dollars a
year for medicare for all by some
studies i don't
depending on which portions of the green
new deal you pick to do first that's
money
uh that you know what the republicans
are gonna say tax and spend liberals pie
in the sky
one of the things that i admire and
respect is the measurement
that is captured in three letters roi
what's the return on the investment
people in the private sector understand
this really well
it's not about a cost it's about an
investment and then the question should
be
is it worth the cost in terms of the
investment potential are we going to get
back more than we put in
that's that's really what it's about
don't worry about the cost guys cost is
of no consequence whatsoever by the way
how radical it's coming here so remember
that time i said that she's really
willing to like say or like a few
minutes ago and i said she's basically
willing to say or do anything to get
ahead and i talked about her
prosecutorial record
and how there are a lot of people on the
left and on sort of the libertarian
right who are upset with the fact that
she was very much in favor of jailing
low-level drug offenders by the way
again i've lived in california my entire
life the crime rates here have been
not great for a very long time and she
was of
very little help as attorney general of
the state of california
well she was specifically asked the
other day about defunding the lapd
so she has not come out full skill and
embrace defund the police but she was
very much in favor of cutting the
funding to the los angeles police
department in the aftermath of riots
that shut down the city of los angeles
night on night for a week entire county
of l.a shut down
at 6 p.m for a week so that riders and
looters could have their way with the
local foot locker and kamala harris went
on national tv and said we should
probably
cut funds to the lap but don't don't
worry guys she is a radical
she is she's not a radical she's she's a
pragmatic
moderate who is going to enforce the law
and ensure that you and your family i
mean look at her record as prosecutor
it's not as though she would use power
conveniently
and for whatever she decided to use it
for that day and there's a person who
cares deeply about you and your family
and keeping you safe
here's kamala harrison we should slash
the budget in l.a
many cities spend over one third of
their entire city budget
on policing but meanwhile we've been
defunding public schools for years in
america
we've got to re-examine what we're doing
with american taxpayer dollars and
ask the question are we getting the
right return on our investment
are we actually creating healthy and
safe communities
and that's a legitimate conversation and
it requires a
really critical evaluation i applaud
eric garcetti for doing what he's done
so don't worry guys we can rely on her
she's
she's definitely going to keep america
safe as well i think that
in essence to sum up joe biden has made
a major boo-boo here his major boo-boo
is that he has basically given away the
game we all know that he's a temporary
stand-in for whatever comes next and
what he has decided comes next is that
so if you would like that meaning a a
kamala harris administration
all the policies all the
authoritarianism all the opportunism
all the the high-handed unwillingness to
listen to opposing points if if that is
what you are in the game for
then by all means vote for joe biden
vote for joe biden because you're going
to vote for biden what you're going to
get is kamal harris that's what the
american people must understand
that is what donald trump should
campaign on i i think this is a massive
strategic blunder
by joe biden we're gonna find out in
very short order alrighty later today
we'll be here for two additional hours
of content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nica geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses
are life family faith
those are fundamental and that's what
this show is about hope you'll
give it a listen